welcome back how a pornified culture
created an explosion of sexual abuse in
America
and how it could be destroying our
children's future that's tonight's angle
the only thing that seems to knock the
Russia story off the headlines these
days are reports of rampant sexual abuse
in Hollywood
whether it's Miramax founder Harvey
Weinstein facing multiple claims of rape
oscar-winning actor Kevin Spacey accused
of pedophilia or even Hollywood legend
Dustin Hoffman confronting sexual
harassment allegations it's clear that
something is deeply wrong in Hollywood
but of course it's not just the media
and entertainment industry today we
learned that the scandal has moved to
the world of high finance three women
including two Playboy Playmates filed a
twenty seven million dollar lawsuit
against George Soros is former fund
manager Howie Rubin the women alleged he
brutally raped them in a Manhattan sex
dungeon just when you thought things
couldn't go lower but it's important to
remember that none of this none of it is
happening in a vacuum Hollywood in the
media have been ratcheting up sex and
violence on screen and in print for
decades every year a new envelope is
pushed so we shouldn't have been
surprised by these scandals we should
have expected them it's hard to pick out
exactly when all of this started but a
good place to look is the founding all
those years ago in nineteen fifty three
of Playboy magazine the publication's
founder Hugh Hefner essentially
mainstream porn with his glossy peanuts
sometimes celebrity sometimes not but I
know everyone everyone just bought the
magazine what for the interviews and the
gore Vidal essays here's how half
himself defined his own legacy what do
you want your legacy to be do you want
to go you have no business man civil
rights activists philanthropist somebody
who played some positive part in the
changing social
sexual values of my time and I think I'm
pretty secure on that but you don't
think that playboy at all made women
objects rather than equals I think that
women in the best sense and not in a
negative sense our object of desire well
at least he's honest social sexual
values of our time well the robed Pied
Piper of porn whistled a tune of
objectification and the whole world
followed but how did Hollywood react
when he passed away in September of
course utter adulation Kim Kardashian
tweeted on September 28th r.i.p to
legendary Hugh Hefner I'm so honoured to
have been a part of the Playboy team
Jenny McCarthy 1993 Playmate of the Year
lauded half quote for being a
revolutionary and changing so many
people's lives I'll say bear in mind
this was just a week before the Harvey
Weinstein scandal was blown open by the
New York Times Hollywood treated this
dirty old man like a newly minted Saint
the sexual abuse scandals are partly a
case of life imitating art and I use
that term art loosely have normalized
the objectification of women and
Hollywood up the ante look at Kevin
Spacey in the movie American Beauty he
played a suburban father who has sexual
fantasies about his daughters underage
friend Hollywood was so enamored with
his performance that they gave Spacey
and Oscar for that role what was the
impact of those images I wonder and
might they have contributed maybe a
little bit to the abuse of underaged
minors at least made people kind of numb
to it and Hollywood tripped over itself
spending millions of dollars to adapt
the so called mommy porn Fifty Shades of
Grey series for those that don't know
those books and films revolve around a
young woman who begins a sadomasochistic
relationship with a young billionaire on
the far side of abuse and degradation
she finds true love just what we want
for our girls
it even NBC's Today Show held a contest
so excited mothers and their daughters
could attend an early screening of the
film the point of vacation of the
culture and a sexual deviancy it's
created is not confined to the remote
worlds of entertainment finance in the
media of course this is killing intimacy
it's killing relationships and there are
now reports of the run the rise of sex
spots sex robots in virtual reality porn
people just won't do real relationships
anymore this is numbing them to what a
real relationship is in my deep concern
and all of this it's for the children
who stumble across a website on their
iPad or an image and are quickly
transported to a very dark place that
could very well destroy their own
emotional futures and that's the angle
joining us now with reaction from Boston
dr. Gail Dinah's founder and president
of the culture reframed an author of
porn land how porn has hijacked our
sexuality along with dr. Karen Ruskin a
marriage and family therapist it's great
to see both of you this Friday night
this explosion of sexual harassment
allegations leading the way to more
revelations of more depravity that story
about that sex dungeon and it's a fun
manager for George Soros it's getting
more violent it's getting more depraved
if possible it's getting more depraved
and it's it's becoming I mean I don't
even you can't even describe this on
television it's so filthy
tell us about dr. Ruskin we'll start
with you the effect on children that we
know of now with how early they're
seeing the sexual images and what it's
doing to their own sense of emotional
development for young children my
biggest concern is what I'm seeing in
front of me is that they are believing
that unhealthy relationships are healthy
we're actually transforming what is
deemed a loving healthy relationship
between two people and
with a family what used to be considered
deviance is now considered acceptable
there's no longer black and white
everything is gray everything is
acceptable and if I want something when
I want it then I get to have it and that
is what children are learning and that
is danger written all over it on every
level when there is no longer right from
wrong
dr. Dinah's well what we know from
studies is that the average age of a kid
first a boy looking at pornography is 12
now this is not accidental what's
happened is that thanks to the free porn
business model which was developed by a
group called mine geek which is based in
Luxembourg when that made pornography
affordable it made it anonymous and it
made it accessible the three A's that
drive demand and that really took off
around 2009 now who is gonna go to a
free porn site those who haven't got any
money those who haven't got credit cards
children so I would really argue that
the business model of pornography was to
get in the boys around 12 to 14 whose
brains are actually hardwired for
novelty and risk-taking because if it's
like me giving out cigarettes outside a
middle school at 12 years old
and going back each day in each day and
well so standing - so kids excuse me so
just so we understand this so especially
young boys are for the first time seeing
the image of a female body and in some
of these cases the type of images
they're seeing are so violent in their
depiction or so extreme that this is
what they become used to or that they
want and then that put put pressure dr.
dr. love get on on the girls to perform
just in the same way I actually own one
at a time dr. Watson and I'll actually
say this is this is not just for boys
this is boys and girls yes even younger
in my practice I'm seeing as a therapist
it's much younger than 12 and this is
being depicted not just with TV shows
this is
music this is in magazines this is in
even if you look online there's pictures
of animals
that's animated art that look like
humans and there's very inappropriate
behavior that those animals that look
like human are doing and young children
are seeing that as young as five six
seven eight and they are moving their
bodies so what they are seeing both boys
and girls and doctor dinos what does
this do ultimately it didn't just as a
woman you think about this to a young
person it's understanding of of intimacy
real intimacy and love and and respect
does is it enhance it but from what
we've seen from 1953 all the way to
today no what well we have to think
about pornography today which is not
your father's Playboy as bad as that was
I mean really a bit ironic but I kind of
look back with nostalgia at that because
what we have now as mainstream porn is
so hardcore
that in our fathers generation you had
to go to a porn store know somebody who
could get you access to that level of
hardcore that is now mainstream and
that's what I think a lot of people
don't understand they think that maybe
boys a little Howie would help make it
mainstream my point is that Hollywood
media advertising agencies the entire
media apparatus books Fifty Shades of
Grey this all helped numb people to this
this mainstream the whole thing and so
now we turn around oh how surprising
that yeah like teenagers have have an
explosion and STDs or or girls or
alright you know dressing like you know
a little prostitutes I mean this
continuum it's a continuum dr. Ruskin
last word yes you you are so right the
purification of America has
creepy-crawly into our home our
marriages our families and we're not
even consciously realizing it now we're
realizing it
couples need to be more yeah so many
parents have a nightmare ladies parents
have to be the first line of defense for
their kids
yeah parents we're gonna we're gonna
have both yeah we're gonna have both of
you back because this is a problem it's
not going away and we're gonna look for
solutions real solutions for parents who
want help for their kids thank you so
much